he is an
llm postdoctoral fellow and a phd
candidate
in the health and clinical informatics
program in d mice
he received his md degree with a double
major in traditional chinese
medicine at chiang kang university in
taiwan
he received his master's degree in
biomedical engineering from carnegie
mellon university in pittsburgh
he finished two years of medical
resident training in taipei city
hospital
and worked as a research associate on
the clinical research team for two years
at the university of pittsburgh
its current research projects are
related to the secondary use of ehr data
with machine learning algorithms to
improve
clinic workflow efficiency and for
uh progression prediction and risk
assessment of glaucoma
uh with the ehr data today he's uh
defending his dissertation proposal
so we chen if you'd like to start
sharing your screen
and um and welcome to everyone
okay
so can you see the screen and
hear my voice yes
okay thank you everyone to join today's
meeting
i'm going to talk about application of
machine learning for glaucoma
using ehr data in the beginning
i would like to thank you all my
dissertation advisory community
dr chan dr huibar dr chen
dr song and everyone in demise the
research was funded by national library
of medicine training grant
so the first question is what is
glaucoma glaucoma is a group of eye
disease characterized by progressive
degeneration of optical nerve
and the visual field laws that are
irreversible
the most common type of glucomancer is
open angle glycol
and in our study we will focus on the
open-ended glaucoma
side figure shows the structure of
glaucoma
so we can see in the glaucoma eye
the outflow of adequate humor was
blocked
and it increased the intraocular
pressure
and in my damage to the optic nerve
glaucoma is the second leading cause of
blindness
in the world in 2020
the estimation number of glaucoma cases
is more than
65 million and in u.s glaucoma affects
about 2
patients that older than 40 years old
in the early and middle stage there are
no significant glaucoma
the the only symptom we can observe is a
slowly progressive visual field
decrease several eye exam can be used to
make diagnosis of glaucoma
include intraocular pressure test
visual field test and people use the
optic coherence tomography oct to
measure the original nerve fiber layer
thickness
medications are critical for preventing
global progression
the mechanism of medication
either increase the outflow of adequate
humor
or decrease uh adequate humor production
surgical intervention was used for rapid
progression cases
or for some patient day in response to
the
medication therapy both laser and
conventional surgery
allow more outflow of adequate humor
the most common conventional surgery
is trabeculectomy and which removes the
portion of the trabecular network and
increase the outflow of
adequate humor one critical issue of
glaucoma
is rate of progression
and this figure shows um 117
eyes of 86 patients and
the y-axis shows the mean deviation
the mean deviation gives an overall
value of the total amount visual field
loss
with normal value typically within 0 db
to -2 db
the mean deviation value becomes more
negative
at the overall visual field worth so in
this figure we can show some patient
progression with stable
and there's a field patient there
progression improved and uh
some patients show the rapid
progressions
so as showing the figure we can find the
rate of glucose progression if
among patients around
3 to 17 of glaucoma patients show a
rapid progression rate
quickly progression patients are highly
risk
of blindness and the need early
intervention
so early identified rapid progression
patient
is critical to prevent vision loss
however
predict glaucoma progression is not an
easy task glaucoma is a complex and
multifactory disease manufacturers such
as
age gender family history and
some other eye disease the baseline eye
measure
and many factors can associate with
glaucoma progression so the complexity
of disease
made it hard to predict this is
progression
rational learning model is a possible
way to
handle such a high complexity
disease progression and based on the
literature review article
published last year there are about 30 a
study
mainly used structured data and the
functional data for
glaucoma management 31 study focus on
improving diagnosis and
only 730 focus on prediction of
progression based on structure or
functional data
in addition based on our literature
review article we explore the
application of ai technique with ehr
for eye disease there are only two
studies use the machine learning model
with ear job for the glaucoma
management the first the first study
predicting the need for surgical
intervention
and the second study developed a
glaucoma phenotype based
on ehr data and this phenotype was used
to
improve the predictive performance of
image-based classifier
based on this review we found that most
study folks on
improving diagnosis that's easy to
understand since there are leaking a
goal standard tool
for glaucoma diagnosis so many studies
try to find some way to
to to improvement the diagnosis
and the fewer study focus on the
glaucoma progression prediction
and the most the prediction model based
on single mixture like visual field
or original fiber layer sickness however
use single measurement like visual field
change to
operationalize with the glaucoma
progression
may not be comprehensive enough some
clinical feature like
optic desk image can be indicated for
rapid progression
cases in addition there are some
data issues most studies use image data
and there are only two studies as we
show in previous slides
use the ehr data and they only use
structured ear
structure ehr data however some
important features like patients
medication
adherence are recorded in free text data
like
progress note otherwise thai series data
like the
iexan result may not be complete for
many glaucoma patients
for example um the no
observed or missing data of facial field
are common issues things
the patient may not receive visual um
the visual field exam for every visit
so so that's a how to get a
comprehensive data
and uh awkwardly predict ripple
progression patient
it's a challenge work
here list the possible feature for
glaucoma progression
from ehr data including structural data
like um eye exams patients
demographic data patient medical history
and their family history can also
contain the unstructured data
like glaucoma medication and medication
adherence
so we figure out several challenges for
using er
data in predictive model for glaucoma
that such as some important information
and feature was recorded in the
unstructured data like progress node
and time series data like eye
measurement
content some unobserved or missing data
and the use single um single i'm
instrument to
trace the disease progression may not be
comprehensive enough
so for our um study there are two
specific
ends in specific m1 we try to address
the challenge for the secondary use of
ehr data for the prediction model
we use the natural language processing
method to extract feature from
unstructured data
and we will use several analytic methods
for managing missing data
on problem and we will um
overwrite override litization outcome
venture from ribbon disease progression
in specific end tool we will develop
prediction models for rapid glaucoma
progression by
exploring multiple machine learning
methods
we will not only focus on the single
binary outcome
but also explore the prediction for
multi-label classification outcome and
we also want to
identify possible factors for replica
comma progression
so in the m1a we will use natural
language processing to extract feature
from
unstructured data
as showing before medication therapy are
crucial for prevent
glaucoma progression and which is
important to get
correct medication information however
extract medication information from hr
data
is not so easy because
um sometimes medication that is
inaccurate
since some medication um some prescript
take by other plates like cvs and this
change may not be reflecting the
medication that and sometimes that
ex already expired medication still
can see in the medication list and
we'll assume that programs note contain
more accurate recall because physician
will record a patient's medication
change or new medication
for each visit the right side figure
shows two examples of
medication information mismatch the left
side shows
the mismatch of medication this and the
medication
in progress note and right side shows
there some medication information
recorded in the progress note but for
this
this visit there's no medication this
information
here is an example of medication
mismatch
in summary there are two medications
are the same with different rules to
show as red
and the blue color shows the medication
was recalled as brand nan in progress
note but actually it's the same drug
in the medication list and there are
three medications
are different between the medication and
the progress mode
so the first part of m1a we will extract
medication information from progress
note and
check the medication list accuracy
there are two steps for this part the
step one we manually review 150
glaucoma patients program node and their
medication list
and in the step 2 we will use natural
language process to automatically
extract medication information from
progress note and make
the comparison with medication list
in the step 1 the patient's most recent
office visit
will be manually reviewed and any
medication mismatch or
discrepancy between the medication list
and the progress note
uh would be labeled because we have
three reviewers so we
do the cross validation to verify the
review process with
20 random sample nodes after validating
the review process
another 130 progress node was selected
by stratified
sampling method
here is the result of the step one
so because we still working on another
40 progress note so here is just the
result
for the 110 samples
so we can see that around 30 percent
medication
mismatch was found in this
110 samples and
more than half progress no content
at least one mismatch so here we can see
the perfect match medication list and
the
progress note it's 46 percent
after figure out there some problem of
the medication list and the medication
information in the progress node in the
next step with
uh we try to develop a natural language
processing model to extract the
information from progress node
and make comparison to check the
medication that
things manually review this chart and
medication that
is really spend a lot of time and time
consuming
we use the nan entity recognition model
to do this work land entity recognition
model ner
is a task of natural language processing
statistics
and the categorized nan entity in the
body of text
we use the spacey library space c is an
open source library for advanced natural
language processing in python
we trend the ner model with seven nan
entities
include drug names root frequency
dosage trans duration and current drug
use term
the current drug use term is some words
that
are indicating the patient is taking
some drug or stop using some drug food
for example some words like continuous
discontinuous or stop
like current ocular
mass some some specific term that
recognize the patient is taking or stop
the the drug so we add this
um entity with other drug
information to get more accurate uh
patient use
medication usage information
uh more than 1800 sentences were
annotated
and this sentences were split into
training data with 75 percent
and the testing data with 25
the bottom figure shows the on some
example
of the nan entity the green color shows
the dark nand and
here is trans and the red shows the
dosage
here's the root and orange is
uh frequency so that's the example of
annotate sentences
the figure shows the architecture of the
ner model
so the um sentences was extract from the
progress
node and we use a browser-based
annotation tool web anal to annotate the
the sentences and the annotated sentence
with this
will lead to training and testing data
and training data would be used to
trend a spacey ner model we use the
empty english model with
ner pipeline and the trended model was
you
was verified the testing data and used
to
extract the medication information from
the progress node
from other other samples
here is the result of any model with
different proportions of training data
we can see the the largest uh sentences
we have acceptable uh accuracy with f's
one score
equal to 92 for the drug and the
frequency and the root
is um better than the the drug
accuracy um
here is our preliminary preliminary work
and we're still working on
annotating more sentences with different
form
and turning the prediction model to
improve the
the model performance and we will use
this
an er model to extract the medication
information and develop a tool to
check the medication list accuracy
automatically
other than medication um information
some other features um it's also
important for the glaucoma progression
are
like medication adherence medication
adherence is critical for preventing the
disease progression
and studies suggest that non-adherence
in patients with
glaucoma has been reported up to 59
and uh several factors can affect the
glaucoma medication adherence for
example
some eye drop is painful so it's make
difficulty for
patient continue to use these eye drops
and as mentioned before the in the early
and the middle stage
the clean um glaucoma symptom
is not clear not significant glaucoma
symptoms so
some patients just think of motivation
and for some senior patient they may
just forget to take the drug
and uh so so the medication adherence is
pretty
pretty common issue for the glaucoma
patient and
need to extract this information from
the progress
node for a prediction model
in addition some clinical feature can
represent the
ripple disease progression like the
glaucoma patient with optic desk
hemorrhage are likely to show faster
progression rate
but they are similar to the medication
adherence information there are no
specific
structure data we can easily easily to
access uh there's no like specific
code or um some table or
sheet that we can directly extract
so we need to find some way to get this
information
from the unstructured data like progress
note we plan to use task classification
tool to extract
desk hemorrhage and medication adherence
information from the progress
note for glaucoma patient
that's a tax classification is the
process of
categorizing tasks according to its
content
which is a subtask of natural language
processes
this figure shows the basic architecture
of the
text classification model so we need to
extract some progress node and
give the label for the node and the
training model to classify
the node with different label
here is a possible step that we can
handle this
this model so we will manually review
four thousand i don't know
four hundred glaucoma patients progress
note and the
labels note with uh medication adherence
or non-adherence or content
that's hemorrhage information and the
text in the node will transfer
to the numeric factor and this
training data will be used with the
supervised machine learning like support
machine or deep learning model like a
compositional
neural network to classify the nodes
the the model will be evaluated with
precise recall and f manager
and the trended model will be used to
classify the other progress node to
extract
the feature for the prediction model
and in the specific m1b we will use
different
analytic methods for managing missing
data
types missing time series data problem
glaucoma patients are i exam result may
contain many missing data or
unobserved data especially for
like ocd result or i
feature field tests since patients
may not receive all eye exam everything
for example patients routine healthy
glaucoma patients routinely have at
least
two office visits per year for the
glaucoma management
and for some severe symptoms
or repair progress cases they
need more frequency of this visit
and for each visit the patient's
intraocular pressure visual acuity cd
ratio
were recorded but some i mean instrument
like a
visual field measurement oct result are
just
scheduled for the once per year but for
some cases that
can be more open but it's just a roughly
number
but this um this difference leading to
some
unobserved or uh the missing data for
the
for the um for the
uh follow-up physics data set
and sometimes data recall every visit
can be missing or
unusable so all these problems on
the meeting data issue for the
ixan data set
so we will use the um classical
statistic
imputation method to handle this problem
so there are two possible way or
that we can use for handle this issue
include
forward building and linear building
for forward filling involves replacing
the missing data using the last time
point data
and the linear filling use the linear
interpolation between the
previous time data and the next time
point data
in addition we also plan to use some
machine learning model to predict the
missing data
to replace it uh like like
we can use the basic model or random
forest
and as we create a time series
data set for the eye sense we can
try to use the recurrent neural network
to handle the
missing data easy recurrent neural
network is a
type of deep learning and which is good
to handle the time series problem
which can learn the information from
previous prediction
and remember the information from prior
input
throughout the time step in the training
process
as shown in the figure the left side
shows the traditional
forward network and right side shows the
recurrent
neural network one of the main
difference in
this model is how the input data is
taken
in traditional model which takes the
fixed amount of input data
all at the same time and produce a fixed
amount
of output each time and our
recurrent neural network is in contract
it
takes the input data at first
as part as once and
the input data is intake as a sequence
so we can see in the the time one
input data the first time step data
will input the first cell and get the
output
and the output one will transmit to the
um
the next cell and and so on so we can
use this
um model structure to handle the meeting
data for
time series data set
the input data set is different between
the
traditional prediction model and the
recurrent neural network in traditional
prediction models
the input data format in two-dimension
but for recurrent neural network the
input
is three-dimensional so of course the
first label is
each eye of patient and second label is
that each
visit and the third dimension is the eye
measurement
for each visit
in the n1c we will define the
outcome features of the ripple
progression
for coma here is a list of predictors
and outcome features we already extract
and we plan to extract
in the predictive features that contains
uh several i mean instruments and some
patients demographic information
including the insurance status and their
raise and zip code
also some clinical
[Music]
history including family history
smoking history and several
data that extract from the unstructured
data like
medication usage and medication
adherence
and and we um
use three outcome features to define the
ripple progression glaucoma the first
one
is annual visual field loss that larger
than 1.5 db per year
this feature will convert to the binary
variable
and the patient received the glaucoma
surgery
and the patient present the optic desk
hemorrhage
is the another two outcome that used to
define
rapid progression
the figure shows the calculation example
of annual visual field loss the rate of
change of visual field is
expressed in db per year and is derived
by the amount
change in the mean immediately
in in mean deviation that happen over
the target period of time
so this figure here shows the um
the time change is one year and the
change is 1.9
so the slop is 1.9 db
per year so after extract the data
and handle some missing data problem the
next step
in the specific n2 we will develop
prediction model for ripple glacoma
progression
here is the graphical overview of
our specific n2
we handle the some missing data problem
and get data
in the m1 and after doing some data
processing work uh we will develop
several prediction models for both
single output
and multiple uh multi-label output
for a single output we plan to use
linear regression
support vector machine random voice
gradient boosting machine
and actually boost uh to develop to
develop the prediction model
and for the multi-label output we plan
to
use classifier change and the deep
learning like
a multi-layer perceptron model to handle
this
multi-level classification problem
the model will be evaluated with several
metrics for the single output
we will use the accuracy auc
precision recall f1 score
and for the multi-layer multi-label
classification model we will use the
micro
and a marker averaging with the metric
like aoc
score and also use other metrics like a
hamming loss metric
and exact match ratio to evaluate the
multi-label classification model the
feature importance will
be calculated with each model and
used to explore the possible
risk factor related to the ripple
progression so overall the
output of the model will be the feature
importance based on each model and
based on all models and the output of
the
prediction model with for single output
and the multiple label classification
output we also
evaluate the imputation methods
performance
with the prediction model accuracy
so here is the um machine learning model
we plan to use for the single binary
output
including logistic regression support
vector machine
random forest gradient boosting machine
and actual boost
here is the basic idea about this
machine learning models
logistic regression is an extension of
linear regression
which with the sigmoid function
converter
output from the continuous variable to
the binary outcome
and the support fact machine is another
popular user machine learning model
with a hyper plan created to split
input data into two distinct groups and
can be used to classify new data into
similar
distinct categories uh the random forest
actually boots and the gradient booster
machine
is in symbol method with decision trees
on the the enhanced backing mess and
boosting method which used with the
discipline tree and
improve the performance of the model
here is several uh evaluation metrics we
plan to use for the single
output models include accuracy precision
recall f score
and auc score the accuracy was the
method
message
determining the how correct the value
operating
and the precision determined the
reproductibility
of the measurement or in other words it
showed
how many of the predictions were correct
and recall shows that how many of the
correct results were found
and the f uh f1 score is
the measurement method that
com combination with position and the
recall
and it's pretty good for imbalanced
dataset prediction
and we also use the aug score to
evaluate the model ability to
distinguish
to discriminate different categories
we also plan to develop the prediction
model for multi-label classification
the first model we plan to use
is classifier change model in a
classifier
chance the output of one response
variable
for a sub classifier will be used as
an extra feature in the next
subclassifier
this additional features allow each
channel to explore the correlation
among the classes so as shown in the
figure
the output of first the classifier is c1
and the c1 will use as a training set
for the second
classifier and the second classifier get
output as c2 and the c2
plus c1 we're used with the training set
for the uh sorry
for the for the third classifier
and the order of the uh in our study we
have
three outputs and the order of this
output will change to
test the best performance order and
with different machine learning models
also we want to use some deep learning
method to
handle this multi-class problem
deep learning neural network natively
support
multi-label classification problems
which can support by specifying the
number of
target labels there is in the problem as
the number of
nodes in the output layer for example in
our study there we have three output and
individual field loss
uh glaucoma surgery and optic task
hemorrhage
and we will require a neural network
output layer as here with three nodes to
handle this problem
the evaluation matrix is for the
multi-label classifications a little
different from the single output
we will use the hamming loss matrix and
exam match ratio
hemming loss is the fraction of the
labels that
are incorrectly predict or we can say
is the fraction fraction of the wrong
label
to the total number of labels in
contracts
exact match ratio is which indicating
the percentage
of samples that have all their label
classified correctly
and we will use the microaveraging and
the marble averaging with
the evaluation matrix for the single
output
in micro averaging all true positive
true negative
false positive and the false negative
for each class
are sum up and then the average is taken
for the
micro average and the multiple averaging
is more straightforward is just take the
average of the old nature of the system
and we also want to identify the
possible factor
for predicting rip rapid glacoma
progression
as shown in previous slide in the
supervised machine learning model we
will
rank the importance based on
each model and this the future
importance can be
used for identified possible factors
that
related to the disease progression
in addition we we will try to use
unsupervised
learning to i identify cluster within
the data set
so that means we will uh set the
the certain number of cluster of our
dataset and
this cluster can be a glaucoma phenotype
and we can explore the the risk factor
within each phenotype to explore the
the potential risk factor
associated with the rapid glaucoma
progression
so in our study in the m1 we will try to
address the challenge for the secondary
use of ehr data for the glaucoma
progression prediction model we use the
natural language
model to extract the medication
information
and the check the medication this
accuracy and we plan to use other
um uh nlp method to
extract the medication of the current
and the other clinical feature
and we will use analytic method to
manage the missing time stress data
problem
and define the repair progress
progression
with three different variables
and in the end tool we will develop the
prediction model for ripped glacoma
progression
with several machine learning models and
we will focus on both
single output and the multi-label
classification output
and we will try to identify possible
vectors with
supervised and unsupervised machine
learning models
thank you for your attention and all
questions are welcome
thank you waichan very nice job i would
like to open it for
questions from anyone
okay i have a question um could you
describe the data set that you will be
using
for both aim 1 and aim 2 sort of like
you know who the patients are what the
time period is about how many patients
or eyes are in the data set
currently we extract the patient with
glaucoma diagnosis both in the glaucoma
specialty
and other um other specialties
for from 2013 and we
extend two years before 2013
and there are during that period we have
around
6 000 patients with a lot of
uh different i mean german and
demographic data but
some we're still working on this extract
like visual field and ocd result because
uh the iprox system was installed
after 2017. so before that time period
that uh we need to find some way to
extract more data before
2010 okay thank you
um yeah i've got a question
okay hello um yeah this is home merchant
um
very interesting work you know one
question i have is are you planning to
use
a data set to build a model and then a
separate data set to evaluate it or
how are you going to evaluate it um yeah
the
the data set we when we create a data
set we will
uh split to the testing data and
training data and
use quote validation method to make sure
that the training data is not
overfeeding
um i'm sorry how are you going to do
that you're going to use a training data
set and then
a separate data set oh no he
created the same data set and just speak
to the training data and testing data
so we will verify with the testing data
and testing data
will not leak it to the training model
um you're going to use the same data set
for both the training and testing
well if you're training using a data set
then
de facto it's going to be pretty good
for testing but it could be an overfit
um yeah we might use uh close validation
like 10 volt close
validation or
[Music]
trapping method to try to add the
confidence
of the prediction model and decrease the
overfitting problem
all right
i can just chime in there i i think
that'll be a very good idea
um to do that sort of cross validation
because i think you'll find
with especially with the rnns and the
larger models that um overfitting will
happen
um for sure yeah
any other questions or comments
just a very very cool data set and uh a
really good
um preliminary project here so this is
this is really exciting
thank you yeah thanks for showing it
okay well if there aren't any more
questions or comments
then um everyone accepts
the industry's dissertation advisory
committee is free to leave and
uh those of media will remain and um